[Music]
and then before we do anything else
explain spence
okay so
basically i wanted to like dress up a
little bit i'm wearing my i'm wearing my
star wars t-shirt um but i wanted to
represent the trek side so i thought i'd
do some some trill markings on myself
um and what i didn't realize
is i'd accidentally use the permanent
marker
um so i now have
some some very nice drill markings
permanent marker on my face
uh let's see how that goes when i try
and wipe those off
yeah if you don't have a symbiote pouch
you're just not serious so let's see
i i personally love the commitment to it
and that you you you did this so that we
had something to laugh at you
well it wasn't intentional but hey here
we go
the whole time
excellent okay good just stop just don't
be pounding and things because it's a
bit
but i've never had actors
i mean he stole everything you didn't
even know what i mean even with all the
makeup he stole every scene he was in
it was that bit where he was saying
about when he was and i don't remember
obviously i didn't speak klingon but
like um apart from a couple of phrases
but when he was talking about he was
saying uh the federation is is is down
in the muck with the andorians and the
and the vulcans and all this and it was
it was you know the tellurites and it
was oh my god like the guy was
incredible the cool and the way he do
you know he was talking about you know
the relationship between klingons and
the federation well the federation
everybody
and here comes the lie
yeah you know and then um georgios says
and we come in peace
yeah well it may have it may have been i
mean in a way i i think they missed out
on an opportunity to to compare that as
almost like a borg comparison because
the way to cover saw it was it was an
assimilation of their culture and
denying them their individuality as a
spacefaring race
there isn't any heart in it i feel like
it's it's it's death by committee i feel
like you've got a
a bunch of people sat there throwing out
ideas
you know and um and basically it's it's
the product of a writer's room that
isn't necessarily
styles fans you know they're they're
they're not people who've been fans of
the you know the movie all the genres
for years of their life they're they're
people that are
hollywood executives who want to make a
a popular science fiction movie right
you know that's my opinion at least of
the sequel trilogy i don't know about
you guys
which are the original cast are we going
to kill in this film
and then which of the things and there's
just it's feeling very formulaic
that's the thing
you say but jar jar binks survives you
know let's kill this guy this guy get
but no let's leave jar jar alone he must
live to the to the heat death of the
that's the point now isn't it he has to
live yesterday
you had the sexual tension between
vision and uh daenerys stormborn you
know
it was just
you've just you've literally proved a
point there where the only reason that
you care about those characters because
they've been other characters
between charleston no you're not right
though
she's been in two big franchises and
she's ruined both of them
he's still behind the production though
isn't it so is there is there an
influence you think they have said look
it needs to be different
you guys have both watched discovery
haven't you yes
do you feel like you've got a good grasp
over the story of picard
it's very forgettable
the uh for me it was like the um the
salvation of the romulan people was like
his
last hurrah you know there was all these
things that he did you know
uh between the the films and this
when it picks up the the the romulan uh
just i mean for me for me it's the case
off right okay so i loved discovery
season one right i loved it okay there's
a lot of inconsistencies
a lot of people didn't like michael
burnham blah blah i loved it i thought
it was great
i thought season two was great but it
got a bit boring you know
i hated picard i thought picab was like
nonsensical
it was like you know maddox had
something to hide
for science fiction storytelling you
know um
the original animated series i've been
back in one second
what was really good
you know and so um
anyway i'll close you know because we've
been only talking about the tv the
broadcast stuff the television series or
the movies
and there's still a huge
breadth and depth of storytelling for
both uh
stories star wars and star trek
in books and comic books and um
some of those do well
some of those really hit hard and uh
some don't
did we lose spins
yeah basically i mean stormy
sums up like you know
i'll tell you what you can be a big fan
of star trek or star wars it doesn't
matter you know
if you're into the new [ __ ] or the old
[ __ ] it doesn't matter as long as you're
interested in it
we can all get on so
have a great night people
oh yeah i'm gonna watch i've got a name
now taval
and anyway and i thought yeah she's
beautiful i'm on board and then the
series was cheat
but anyway
thanks for joining us tonight guys it's
been very welcome
we're definitely gonna have a chat about
stranger worlds coming up very shortly
and then please get in the comments guys
if you want anything else for us to
discuss then please let us know and we
will um have a think about it for future
videos and we'll see what spence is
going to do to himself next time
how do you how are you going to
how are you going to top that
i don't know
yes right yo come on i've been covered
in blood and something oh my gosh what
have you done i tried to do with
balconies
sexy
[Music]
i don't yeah i know i'm the
yeah
with two massive plates
super glued to his head
do that
gonna get a plate cutting it off and
with super glue stop sticking your
tongue out spence
[Music]